This is a 99 percent invisible bonus episode. I'm Roman Mars. Recently, we published an episode called Towers of Silence. It's about how the Parsis in India are grappling with the loss of vultures and how it changed something very intimate and meaningful for the community. It was reported by our own Lash Madan, and it is epic, it is beautiful.
这是一期《99%隐形》的番外节目。我是罗曼·马斯。最近，我们发布了一期名为《沉默之塔》的节目。它讲述了印度的帕西人如何应对秃鹫的消失，以及这如何改变了该社区一些非常私密且意义重大的事物。这期节目由我们的拉莎·马丹报道，它宏大而美丽。
So first of all, go listen to that story if you haven't heard it. It's so good. It's so worth your time. On the one hand, it's a very specific story. It's about a unique set of circumstances that happen to a very specific community. But it also feels universally relevant because it's a story about death and how we choose to transition out of this world. It's about how we might react when there's a major cultural shift that we cannot control. And importantly, it is about a keystone species collapse, which is something that we are on track to see more of in these times.
所以首先，如果你还没听过那个故事，请去听听。它非常棒，非常值得你花时间。一方面，这是一个非常具体的故事。它关于一个特定社区所经历的一系列独特情况。但它也具有普遍意义，因为它讲述的是死亡，以及我们如何选择离开这个世界。它讲述了当我们面对无法控制的重大文化变迁时，我们可能会有怎样的反应。重要的是，它讲述了一个关键物种的崩溃，而这正是我们在当今时代注定会看到更多的情况。
And you, Lasha, collected a ton of information about vulture conservation in your reporting, and it didn't quite fit into the story that we wanted to tell, but it is so vital and so interesting that I wanted to have you on to talk more about that stuff specifically. So where we left off in the episode, there's this hope that the vultures might one day return to the wild in huge numbers.
拉莎，你在报道中收集了大量关于秃鹫保护的信息，虽然它们没能完全放进我们想要讲述的故事里，但它们非常重要且有趣，所以我邀请你来专门谈谈这些内容。我们在节目结尾处提到，人们希望秃鹫有一天能大量回归野外。
So I want to start there. What is the deal with vultures in India, both in the wild and in captivity in present day 2024? Yes. Hi, Roman. Hi. Yeah. There's a lot in here and there's a lot that didn't quite fit into the main episode that I'm excited to talk about. Yeah.
所以我想从这里开始。在2024年的今天，印度的秃鹫在野外和圈养环境中的情况究竟如何？是的。你好，罗曼。你好。是的，这里面有很多内容，也有很多没能放进主节目里，但我很高兴能谈谈这些。
Specifically about all the other ways that humans relate to vultures and all the kind of nerdy stuff about vulture conservation happening right now. So there were three different species that experienced a dramatic decline between 95% to 99%. Today, there are eight vulture conservation and breeding centers in India. And there are a total of about 800 vultures in captivity.
特别是关于人类与秃鹫相处的其他方式，以及现在正在进行的关于秃鹫保护的各种专业知识。当时有三个物种经历了95%到99%的剧烈下降。今天，印度有八个秃鹫保护和繁育中心。圈养的秃鹫总数大约有800只。
It's estimated that throughout India, there were once about 40 million vultures in the wild. Today, that number is in the thousands. And 800 vultures in captivity might sound like a small number, but it should be said that without vulture conservation, these vultures would have been completely extinct by now. So today, thanks to a number of factors, the banning of vulture toxic drugs, public campaigns to use vulture safe drugs, and all the work at these conservation
据估计，整个印度曾经有大约4000万只野生秃鹫。今天，这个数字只有几千只。圈养的800只秃鹫听起来可能很少，但必须说，如果没有秃鹫保护工作，这些秃鹫现在可能已经完全灭绝了。所以今天，得益于多种因素，包括禁用对秃鹫有毒的药物、开展使用秃鹫安全药物的公共宣传，以及这些保护中心为缓慢而耐心地繁育健康秃鹫所做的一切工作。
centers to slowly and patiently breed healthy vultures. Vulture populations in India are not declining. They're not facing extinction. The populations across vulture species have stabilized, but we're not seeing a wholesale increase in the vulture population. So it's not like we can say the work is over. And test releases of these captive vultures are happening. But as we left off in the story, it's largely a waiting game because vulture toxic drugs are still out there in the wild.
印度的秃鹫种群数量没有在下降。它们没有面临灭绝。各个秃鹫物种的种群数量已经趋于稳定，但我们并没有看到秃鹫数量的全面增长。所以我们不能说工作已经结束了。这些圈养秃鹫的放归测试正在进行中。但正如我们在故事结尾所说，这在很大程度上是一场等待的游戏，因为对秃鹫有毒的药物在野外仍然存在。
Yeah. And so what is the process of vulture conservation? Like what do they do? Yeah. So I was lucky enough to visit the largest vulture conservation and breeding center. It's in Punjore in a state of India called Haryana in North India. And it was opened in 2001 by Dr. Vibhu Prakash, who, if you listen to the episode, he is, he refutes the title that he's been given by many people as the vulture king of India. He doesn't like that. But he is considered... the leading vulture biologist.
是的。那么秃鹫保护的过程是怎样的？他们具体做什么？是的。我有幸参观了最大的秃鹫保护和繁育中心。它位于印度北部哈里亚纳邦的旁乔尔。它由维布·普拉卡什博士于2001年开设，如果你听过那期节目，他本人反驳了许多人给他的“印度秃鹫之王”的称号。他不喜欢这个称呼。但他被认为是……顶尖的秃鹫生物学家。
He happened to be doing research kind of begrudgingly on vultures. He wasn't so interested in vultures at the time. This is before the decline because he was more interested in species that were rare or harder to find and cultures were kind of boring to him because they were just everywhere. And then all of a sudden he became the person who happened to have so much knowledge because of the research he'd been doing. And so what did the conservation center actually look like?
他当时是在不情愿的情况下对秃鹫进行研究。在那时，他对秃鹫并不太感兴趣。这是在数量下降之前，因为他当时对稀有或更难找到的物种更感兴趣，而秃鹫对他来说有点无聊，因为它们到处都是。然后突然之间，由于他一直在做的研究，他成了那个恰好拥有最多知识的人。那么保护中心到底是什么样子的呢？
It didn't look quite like what I expected it to look like. It was a bunch of concrete warehouses, essentially. To get there, I drove down, or I was driven down a very windy road. We got lost so many times that we had to stop, pull over multiple times, and ask people, hey, do you know where the Vulture Conservation Center is? Nobody knew what we were talking about. And there's also no signage, by the way. If you remember from the episode, vultures are easily freaked out by humans. Vultures will vomit as a response to being close to humans.
它看起来并不像我预期的那样。它基本上是一堆混凝土仓库。为了到达那里，我沿着一条非常蜿蜒的道路开车，或者说我是被载着走的。我们迷路了很多次，不得不停下来，多次靠边停车，问路人：“嘿，你知道秃鹫保护中心在哪里吗？”没人知道我们在说什么。顺便说一句，那里也没有任何标识。如果你还记得节目里的内容，秃鹫很容易被人类吓到。秃鹫在靠近人类时会呕吐作为反应。
It can also interrupt their laying pattern. All to say that conservationists don't really want these centers to attract a ton of attention or for them to randomly get curious visitors. Which for me meant that it was hard to find, but eventually I did get there and I was given a tour by Nikita Prakash. Nikita currently runs the center.
这也会打断它们的产卵模式。总之，保护主义者并不真的希望这些中心吸引大量关注，也不希望有好奇的游客随意闯入。对我来说，这意味着它很难找，但我最终还是到了那里，并由尼基塔·普拉卡什带我参观。尼基塔目前负责管理该中心。
She also happens to be the wife of Vibhu Prakash. Together they've been involved in vulture research and conservation for decades. Wow, it's very tall. These aviaries. 20 feet high, 40 feet wide, and 100 feet long. I mentioned it was the largest. So there's 800 vultures in captivity total throughout India.
她恰好也是维布·普拉卡什的妻子。几十年来，他们一直共同参与秃鹫的研究和保护工作。哇，这些鸟舍非常高。20英尺高，40英尺宽，100英尺长。我提到过这是最大的。所以印度全国总共有800只圈养秃鹫。
This center has 400 of them. Oh, wow. And you know, there's a bunch of different rooms, a breeding room, there's an incubation room. This is our incubation and brooder room. Shall I show you from inside? There's a little warehouse looking thing where they house the food for the vultures,
这个中心就有400只。哦，哇。你知道，这里有很多不同的房间，一个繁育室，一个孵化室。这是我们的孵化和育雏室。我从里面给你展示一下好吗？有一个看起来像小仓库的地方，他们存放秃鹫的食物，
which is all goat. So that is our food processing room. When the goats are brought here, then we, according to the number of vultures, we prepare and we provide them. And then there's just rows and rows of cement aviaries. You can't really get a clear view of vultures except through these windows that are cut through the cement. And inside, vultures sit on ledges and perches embedded into the walls. There's a roof made of strong metal mesh to make sure that no other animals, like leopards and whatnot, will get inside. Every aviary has four baths that are cleaned twice a week.
全都是山羊肉。所以那是我们的食物加工室。当山羊被带到这里时，我们会根据秃鹫的数量进行准备并提供给它们。然后就是一排排的水泥鸟舍。你无法通过这些切开水泥的窗户清楚地看到秃鹫。在里面，秃鹫坐在嵌入墙壁的壁架和栖木上。屋顶由坚固的金属网制成，以确保没有其他动物，比如豹子之类的，能钻进去。每个鸟舍都有四个水槽，每周清洗两次。
Also twice a week, the vultures are fed, and they're fed through a little door where skinned goat carcasses are just slid through. Wow, this feels like a lot of effort to maintain. Yeah. I mean, the two of them are so committed. They're so committed to this work. Nikita told me that the religion she practices is called Jainism. And in Jainism, you don't eat meat, but in addition to meat, you also don't eat anything that grows underground.
同样每周两次，秃鹫会被喂食，它们通过一个小门被喂食，去皮的山羊尸体就是从那里滑进去的。哇，这感觉需要付出很多努力来维持。是的。我的意思是，他们两个非常投入。他们对这项工作非常执着。尼基塔告诉我，她信奉的宗教叫耆那教。在耆那教中，你不吃肉，而且除了肉，你也不吃任何在地底下生长的东西。
So garlic, eggs, onions, or eggs don't grow underground, so garlic, onions, you know, and yet she watches 400 vultures eat skinned goat meat twice a week with an extreme dedication. And yet you watch the vultures consume. I've eaten nestlings on goat meat. And you say that with a big smile. Now I'm used to it. It's very interesting. So there's one other room at the Conservation Center.
所以大蒜、洋葱，或者鸡蛋——鸡蛋不是在地底下长的，所以大蒜、洋葱，你知道，尽管如此，她还是以极大的奉献精神看着400只秃鹫每周两次吃去皮的山羊肉。你看着秃鹫进食。我甚至喂过雏鸟吃山羊肉。你笑着说出这句话。现在我已经习惯了。这非常有趣。保护中心还有一个房间。
It's a pretty simple room. The biggest thing, the most obvious thing that's in there is a large monitor that has a series of CCTV cameras on them. It's a control room, essentially. And Vibhu and Nikita and a lot of their staff spend a lot of time in there. And this is how they observe vulture behavior. I learned that sometimes Vibhu would even sleep in the room and occasionally watch the CCTV screen just to make sure that the vultures are doing okay.
那是一个非常简单的房间。里面最大、最显眼的东西是一台大显示器，上面有一系列闭路电视摄像机。它基本上是一个控制室。维布、尼基塔和他们的许多员工花了很多时间在那里。这就是他们观察秃鹫行为的方式。我了解到，有时维布甚至会睡在房间里，偶尔盯着闭路电视屏幕，只是为了确保秃鹫一切安好。
Every time an egg is to hatch, he sleeps here to make sure that it hatches. Do you have children? Yeah, we have two boys. All these 400 vultures are kind of like your wild children. Yeah, I mean, I took care of newborn twins. It sounds exactly the same. You're just like always making sure they're alive. Yeah, and I mean, the one major difference, I guess, is in their case, the whole future
每次有蛋要孵化，他都会睡在这里，确保它能孵化出来。你们有孩子吗？是的，我们有两个男孩。这400只秃鹫就像你们的野生孩子一样。是的，我的意思是，我照顾过刚出生的双胞胎。听起来完全一样。你就像总是确保它们还活着。是的，我的意思是，我想一个主要的区别在于，在他们的情况下，整个物种的未来都寄托在他们的奉献上。所以，是的，这压力很大。在印度新冠疫情最严重的时候，一切都高度军事化并处于封锁状态。因此，维布、尼基塔和他们的员工真的很难到达保护中心，因为要旅行，你需要通过各种检查站。但他们也真的很难找到足够的肉，找到足够的食物让秃鹫生存。他们非常担心。他们告诉我，他们工作到精疲力竭。在新冠期间，我们并不担心自己。
of a species is kind of riding on their dedication. So it's, yeah, it's a lot. And during the height of COVID in India, everything was highly militarized and locked down. And so Vibhu and Nikita and their staff really struggled to get to the conservation center because to be able to travel you needed to move through various checkpoints. But then they also really struggled to find enough meat, to find enough food for the vultures to survive. And they were really worried. They told me they worked until they wilted. During Corona, we were not worried for ourselves.
我们担心的是秃鹫，担心它们的食物从哪里来。是的，我的意思是，我们会做噩梦，担心如何弄到食物。我们甚至考虑过放生它们，因为有一次我们整整一周都弄不到食物。但如果放生它们，那会发生什么呢？所以尽管有所有的障碍和限制，我们还是每天都来中心。每天。然后动员森林部门，因为他们有权限，他们可以给你许可去获取食物。哇，你们做到了。我们做到了。你们每周都能喂养秃鹫。
We were worried about the vultures, how food will come for them. Yeah, I mean we would get nightmares, how to get food. And we were contemplating releasing them because we were, one week we could not get food. But release them, then what will happen? So in spite of all the barriers and restrictions we would come to the center every day. Every day. And then mobilize the forest department because they can they have access they can give you permission to get food. Wow and you did it. We did it. You were able to feed the vultures every week.
每周。那么这项工作有得到很多支持吗？其他人是否意识到这有多重要？正如你可能想象的那样，秃鹫不是一种性感的动物。它们无法与老虎保护所获得的关注和资金相提并论。秃鹫保护不仅要面对公众的冷漠，还要面对积极的恐惧。很多人害怕秃鹫。我采访过一位秃鹫生物学家，他告诉我他有一次在印度的一个村庄做研究和
Every week. So is there a lot of support for the work? Do other people recognize how important this is? As you can probably imagine, vultures are not a sexy animal. They don't compare to the amount of attention and money that tiger conservation gets, for example. And vulture conservation also has to contend with not only public apathy, but active fear. A lot of people fear vultures. I spoke to one vulture biologist who told me about a time he was doing research and
捕捉秃鹫。他了解到，在这个地区，秃鹫被视为一种非常不祥的预兆，如果看到它们落在某人的房子上，人们会认为这意味着那房子里有人要死了。所以他们会拆掉那所房子，搬出去并盖一栋新房子。很难让有钱的人，包括政府，看到秃鹫作为关键物种有多重要，它们的保护真的非常重要。这也非常昂贵，因为每一只山羊
trapping vultures in a particular village in India. And he learned that in this area, vultures were such a bad omen that if they were seen to be landing on someone's house, it was thought that what that meant is that someone in that house is going to die. And so what they would do is dismantle that house, move out and build a new home. It's hard to get people who have money, including governments, to see how important vultures are as a keystone species, that their conservation is really important. It's also really expensive because for each goat
都要经过测试，以确保山羊体内的东西不会杀死秃鹫。这非常昂贵。所以秃鹫保护工作正面临着对大量资金的需求。是的，我们知道秃鹫对印度的帕西人一直意义重大，但秃鹫的缺席给整个印度带来了哪些其他变化？它改变了，你知道，秃鹫制造了这个真空。秃鹫是关键物种，这意味着如果这个物种消失或数量大幅减少，
to go through the testing to make sure that what's in the goat system will not kill the vultures. That's really expensive. And so vulture conservation is contending with just the need for a lot of money. Yeah, so we know that the vultures have always meant a great deal to the parses in India, but what other changes has the vulture's absence brought about to India as a whole? It's changed, you know, the vultures created this void. Vultures are a keystone species, which means if this species disappears or dramatically reduces in size,
它会改变一切。所以当秃鹫还在的时候，印度存在一个非常特定的循环，每当牛的尸体或任何其他种类的动物尸体死亡时。动物的尸体过去就直接留在乡村各处。一头牛死在田野里，他们就把它留在那里，秃鹫就会来。非常方便，非常顺手。
it shifts everything. So when vultures were around, there was this very specific cycle that existed in India whenever a cow carcass or any other kind of animal carcass would die. The carcasses of animals used to just be left all over the countryside. A cow dies in the field, they just leave it and the vultures would come. Very convenient, very handy.
不需要触碰它，不需要移动它。这些牛大多是自然死亡的，秃鹫一直是可靠的清理队。所以一头牛死了，然后印度一群被称为“剥皮人”的人就会过来，他们会剥掉牛皮。这些剥皮人通常随叫随到，他们会带着一队人出现。有时剥皮人会通过观察天空，看看秃鹫开始盘旋的大致区域来寻找工作。这说得通。这项工作很辛苦，而且通常这种工作是通过种姓制度继承的。
Didn't have to touch it, didn't have to move it. Most of these cows are left to die naturally and vultures were always the reliable cleanup crew. So a cow would die, then a group of people in India known as cattle skinners would come and they would skin the cow. Often they'd be on call, these skinners would show up with a crew. Sometimes the skinners would find work by just looking at the sky and seeing where, looking at the general area that vultures were beginning to circle. That makes sense. This work is hard and often it's this kind of work that you inherit through the caste
通常这项工作被指定给低种姓的人。这就是他们谋生的方式。他们把皮卖给皮革工业。但有趣的是，这个过程也帮助了秃鹫。秃鹫不需要它们的食物被剥皮，但一旦剥了皮，秃鹫就更容易接触到肉，因为秃鹫的喙实际上无法穿透牛皮。它太硬了。
system. Often this work is designated to people who are lower caste. And this is how they make their living. They sell the hide to the leather industry. But this process also interestingly helps the vultures. The vultures don't need their food to be skinned, but once it's skinned, it makes it easier for vultures to access the meat because vulture beaks actually can't penetrate cattle skin. It's too tough.
所以它们只能通过眼睛和嘴巴之类的部位接触内脏。所以这只是，稍微有点乱。需要更多时间。所以这不像是一种必需品，但你知道，这确实对它们有一点帮助。是的，是的。说得通。
And so they access the innards only through like the eyes and the mouth and such. And so it's just, it's a little bit messier. It takes more time. So it's not like a necessity, but it's, you know, it helps them out a little bit. Yeah, yeah. Makes sense.
所以，好吧。牛死了，剥皮人来了，现在秃鹫也来了。一旦秃鹫完成了它们的工作，另一组被称为“拾骨者”的工人就会过来，他们收集剩下的骨头并卖掉这些骨头，这就是他们赚钱的方式。
And so, okay. So the cow dies, the skinners come, and now the vultures are here. Once the vultures do their job, a separate group of workers called bone collectors come and they collect the bones that are left and they sell these bones and that's how they make their money.
这些骨头大多卖给了化肥公司。哇。所以这整个经济循环都是围绕着牛的自然死亡展开的。没错。所以当秃鹫不再出现时，这个循环就打破了。人们曾试图实施一种名为“尸体倾倒场”的系统，本质上就是城镇和村庄郊区的尸体垃圾填埋场。当秃鹫不再出现时，大多数城镇和村庄开始建立这些
And these bones are mostly sold to fertilizer companies. Wow. So it's this whole economic cycle all around the natural death of a cow. Exactly. So when the vultures stopped coming, this cycle broke. And there was an attempt to implement a system called carcass dump sites, essentially carcass landfills on the outskirts of towns and villages. And when the vultures stopped coming, most towns and villages started creating these
尸体垃圾场。就像，他们收集，出现了新的工作，他们收集尸体，把它们倾倒在这个区域。但这些尸体垃圾场导致了一个新问题。现在当动物死亡，牲畜死亡时，它们被带到这些尸体垃圾场，那里堆满了牛、水牛和，你知道，牲畜。那么这是谁？这是穆尼尔·瓦拉尼。
carcass dumps. Like, they collect, new jobs came up, they collect the carcasses, they dump them in this one area. But these carcass dump sites led to a new problem. Now when animals die, livestock dies, they're taken to these carcass dump sites where piles of cows and buffaloes and, you know, livestock are there. And so who is this? This is Munir Varani.
他是一位猛禽生物学家，在21世纪初与维布·普拉卡什和数十位其他科学家一起工作，得出结论认为双氯芬酸是杀死秃鹫的元凶。我记得你不会在这些尸体垃圾场看到秃鹫，但你会看到成千上万的流浪狗。它们看起来很凶残。我的意思是，那是一件可怕的事情。所以穆尼尔告诉我，这些垃圾场本质上成了流浪狗的滋生地。狗甚至开始在这些牛尸体的肋骨架内繁殖。
He is a raptor biologist who worked alongside Vibhu Prakash and dozens of other scientists back in the early 2000s to conclude that diclofenac was the thing that killed the vultures. I remember that you would not see vultures at these carcass dump sites and you would see thousands of feral dogs. They looked vicious. I mean, it was a scary thing. So Manir told me that these dump sites essentially became a breeding ground for feral dogs. Dogs started to breed even inside the rib cages of these cow carcasses.
天哪，拉莎。罗曼，我有照片，我可以和你分享。好吧，好吧。天哪，拉莎。我有照片，我可以和你分享。好吧，好吧。但我感觉我几乎不需要看。你可以想象。不，我明白了。所以实际上发现，在20世纪90年代和21世纪初秃鹫数量迅速下降的同一时期，印度各地的流浪狗数量增加了550万。
Oh my god, Lasha. Roman, I have photos and I could share them with you. Okay, okay. God, Lasha. I have photos and I could share them with you. Okay, okay. But I feel like I almost don't need to. You can imagine. No, I got it. So it was actually found that the population of feral dogs across India increased by 5.5
罗曼，我不知道你是否知道这一点，但秃鹫只吃死的东西。它们从不攻击活物。是的，但我猜狗会。狗会。它们实际上捕食活物。狗还会传播狂犬病，在印度，狂犬病是一个真正的问题。长期以来，这一直是一个真正的问题。印度是世界上狂犬病相关死亡人数最多的国家。秃鹫的减少与狂犬病病例的增加之间存在非常强的相关性。我的意思是，狗的数量简直呈爆炸式增长，因为现在有超额的食物供应，而这些食物过去秃鹫会处理掉。
million in the same time period that the vulture population was rapidly declining in the 1990s and early 2000s. And Roman, I don't know if you know this, but vultures only ever go after dead things. They never attack the living. Yeah, but I imagine dogs do. Dogs do. They actually prey on the living. Dogs also transmit rabies, and in India, rabies is a real concern. It's been a real concern for a long time. India has the highest number of rabies related deaths in the world. There's a very strong correlation between the decline in vultures and the
我想狗不像秃鹫那样是高效、干净的食客，对吧？它们真的只会把事情搞得一团糟。我的狗就把家里弄得一团糟。你说得对。
number of cases of rabies that have gone up. I mean dog numbers have just skyrocketed because there's a super abundance of food now that is available that vultures used to get rid of in the past. And I imagine that the dogs are not these efficient, clean eaters the way the vultures are, right? They really just make a mess. My dog makes an incredible mess. You're right.
与秃鹫不同，狗，或者任何其他会去吃尸体的动物。所以狗、老鼠、其他猛禽，就像我们在节目中提到的，鸢和乌鸦。这些动物都没有能力完全消耗掉一具尸体。它们很挑剔。所以这意味着环境上发生了两件事。第一是这些狗，它们更有可能传播秃鹫历史上防止传播的疾病。记住，秃鹫的胃实际上比电池酸还要酸。它可以消耗掉所有恶心的东西并直接杀死它。它可以在体内杀死它，对吧？但这些狗，它们只是传播这些
Unlike vultures, dogs, really anything else that would go for the carcass. So dogs, rats, other birds of prey like we mentioned in the episode, kites and crows. None of these animals are able to consume a carcass entirely. They're picky. And so what this means is two things happen environmentally. The first is that these dogs, they are more likely to transmit the diseases that the vultures have historically prevented from spreading. Remember that the vulture's stomach is actually more acidic than battery acid. It can consume all the gnarly stuff and just kill it. It can kill it inside its body, right? But these dogs, they just pass on these
疾病。所以这导致了潜在的更高的感染率。第二件事，第二种重大的环境后果是，因为没有其他动物能消耗掉整具尸体，存在一种风险，即死尸物质，无论里面有什么，疾病或其他什么，它都可以扩散到水和土壤中。它可以渗入水和土壤，因为遗骸没有完全消失。所以，这真是一团糟。是的。我的意思是，这就是你所说的关键物种。我的意思是，就像整个系统崩溃了。而且问题在于，它不是那种人类肉眼能立刻看到的东西。你知道，我发现帕西人在秃鹫问题上的经历非常引人注目，
diseases. And so it leads to potentially higher rates of infection. And the second thing, the second kind of big environmental consequence is that because there's no other animal that consumes an entire carcass, there's this risk that the dead carcass matter, whatever is in it, a disease or whatever, it can spread into the water and the soil. It can leach into the water and the soil because the remains are not totally gone. And so, it's a whole mess. Yeah. I mean, this is what you mean by keystone species. I mean, just like the whole system collapses. And the thing is that it's not something that is so visible to the human eye right away. You know, the thing that I found so compelling about the the the Parsi experience when it comes to vultures is
因为它非常具体。有时，你知道，为了让人类关心并真正看到变化，它需要非常直观。我认为这就是让它如此引人注目的原因。但所有这些事情也都在背景中发生。这有点难看到，但我们也应该关心。最近有两位环境经济学家发表了一项大型研究，审视了印度的秃鹫以及秃鹫在印度的环境后果和经济后果。他们发现，平均而言，人类死亡
that it's so tangible. And sometimes, you know, in order for humans to care and to really see a change, it needs to be really in your face. And I think that's what made it so compelling. But all of this stuff is also happening in the background. That's a little bit harder to see that we should also care about. Recently there were two environmental economists who published this big body of work looking at vultures in India and the environmental consequences and economic consequences of vultures in India. They found that on average human death
率在这些鸟类几乎灭绝后，在他们所谓的“适合秃鹫生存的地区”据称增加了4%以上。所以他们的意思是，在他们调查的那些秃鹫曾经大量存在而现在不再存在的地区，一般死亡率似乎增加了4%。很大一部分归因于狂犬病，但死亡原因可能多种多样。他们还发现有证据表明，这些地区的流浪狗数量增加，狂犬病增加，水质下降。哇。
rates supposedly increased by more than 4% in what they call vulture-suitable districts after these birds nearly went extinct. So what they mean is that in the areas that they surveyed where vultures used to exist in high numbers and are now no longer there, the general mortality rate has seemed to increase by 4%. A large portion of this is attributed to rabies, but it could be all sorts of reasons for mortality. And they also found evidence that there's been an increase in feral dog populations and rabies and lower water quality in these regions. Wow.
好吧，所以很明显，这些秃鹫在印度的废物管理方面留下了一个真空，它们充当了这个国家的免疫系统。那么现在该怎么办？你如何填补这个真空？因为显然狗做不到，尸体垃圾场也做不到。那么现在该怎么办？你如何填补这个真空？因为显然狗做不到，尸体垃圾场也做不到。就像，你该怎么办？是的，这几乎让情况，我的意思是，这让情况变得更糟了。
Okay, so it's clear that these vultures have left a void when it comes to waste management in India, and they operated as this kind of immune system for the country. And so what do you do now? How do you fill this void? Because clearly the dogs aren't doing it and the carcass dumps aren't doing it And so what do you do now? How do you fill this void? Because clearly the dogs aren't doing it and the carcass dumps aren't doing it. Like, what do you do? Yeah, it's almost making it, I mean, it's making it worse.
这让情况变得更糟了，是的，没错。是的，这是一个非常棘手且有趣的问题。所以我发现，印度各地的市政政府，不是全部，但有些，一直在试图弄清楚如何实施可持续的基础设施，来完成秃鹫几千年来在废物管理和卫生服务方面所做的工作，
It's made it worse, yeah, exactly. Yeah, it's a really tough and interesting problem. So what I found is that municipal governments all over India, not all, but some, have been trying to figure out how to implement sustainable infrastructure to do the job that vultures did for millennia when it comes to waste management and sanitation services
而这些服务是秃鹫提供的。所以有些城市正在努力解决诸如“我们是否应该焚烧牛以防止疾病传播？”之类的问题。如果我们这样做，我们需要经历什么样的基础设施障碍，才能确保人们在建成后会这样做？或者我们应该掩埋它们？
that the vultures provided. And so there are municipalities that are grappling with questions like, do we incinerate cows to prevent disease from spreading? If we do, what are the kind of infrastructural hoops we need to go through to like, one, make sure that people will do this once we build it? Or should we bury them?
我们应该把尸体垃圾场作为官方解决方案，并以某种方式试图阻止狗进入吗？所以印度不同的地方正在尝试不同的可能性，但每个想法都伴随着自己的一系列障碍。掩埋和焚烧需要花钱，如果负担落在农民或牛主身上，让他们支付处理死牛的费用，而在此生态转变之前，他们根本不需要做任何事。他们会吗？穆尼尔实际上告诉我，有些人只是把死
Should we make carcass dump sites the official solution and somehow try to prevent dogs from getting in or something. So different places in India are trying different possibilities, but each idea comes with its own set of hurdles. Burial and incineration cost money, and if the burden is on the farmer or the cattle owner to pay for disposing of its dead cattle when prior to this ecological shift they had to do absolutely nothing. Are they going to? Manir actually told me that some people just dump their dead
动物扔进恒河，因为这是最便宜的选择。所以你现在有这些肿胀的尸体漂浮在河里。哦，天哪。那是一幅可怕的肿胀牛尸体漂浮在河里的画面。哦，天哪，那是一幅可怕的肿胀牛尸体漂浮在河里的画面。是的。而且我们还看到，随着印度政府努力创建和实施新的基础设施系统，这些系统很可能会，在某些地方已经，使那些剥皮人和拾骨者的工作面临风险，因为如果牛被运往焚烧中心，它们
animals into the Ganga because it's the cheapest option. And so you've got these bloated carcasses now just floating down the river. Oh dear God. That's an awful image of a bloated cow carcass floating down the river. Oh dear God, that's an awful image of a bloated cow carcass floating down the river. Yeah. And what we're seeing too is that as India's governments grapple with creating and implementing a new system of infrastructure, these systems will very likely, and in some places already have, put the jobs of those cattle skinners and bone collectors at risk because if cows are being shipped off to an incineration center they
就不再需要被剥皮了。所以，有没有希望把这些圈养的800只秃鹫放归，并开始解决其中一些问题，至少以一种小规模的方式？在想要放归这些秃鹫和不想把它们送去送死之间，有一条非常细的界限。正如主节目中提到的，这些药物，这些有毒药物仍然存在，而且数量还在增加。其中一些正在慢慢被禁止。
don't need to be skinned anymore. So is there any hope to take you know these 800 vultures that are in captivity and release them and begin to solve some of these problems, at least in a small way? It's a really thin line between wanting to release these vultures and not wanting to send them off to their death. As mentioned in the main episode, these drugs, these toxic drugs are still out there and they're increasing in number. And some of them are slowly getting banned.
其中两种较新的有毒药物在2023年被禁止。但同样，我们也了解到，禁止一种药物并不一定等于消灭环境中的这种药物。所以，是的，这就是支持这项保护工作的生物学家们真正、真正感到棘手的事情。因为他们根本无法控制广大民众手中的药物。是的，所以主要的秃鹫保护中心，我参观的那个，正式名称是旁乔尔的贾塔尤保护和繁育中心。那个名字，贾塔尤，它引用了一个关于名为贾塔尤的秃鹫神的特定印度教神话。
Two of these newer toxic drugs were banned in 2023. But again, we also learned that banning a drug doesn't necessarily equal to the eradication of the drug in the environment. And so, yeah, and this is the thing that biologists who are behind this conservation work are really, really grappling with. Because they can't control the drugs in the wider populace at all. Yeah, so the main vulture conservation center, the one I visited, it's formally called the Jatayu Conservation and Breeding Center in Punjur. And that name, Jatayu, it references a particular Hindu myth about a vulture god named Jatayu.
在印度教神话中，有一位秃鹫王，他牺牲了自己的生命来拯救一个受苦的人类。人们认为他活了6000多年。这位秃鹫王以他善良的心和强壮的翅膀而闻名。有一天，他试图拯救一个人的生命。但作为回报，他受伤了，翅膀被切断，他被留在痛苦中等死。哦。我的意思是，他们选择这个名字很有趣，
In Hindu mythology, there's a vulture king, and he sacrifices his life to save a suffering human. He was thought to have lived for over 6,000 years. This vulture king was known for his kind heart and his strong wings. And one day, he tries to save a human life. But in return, he was wounded, his wings were cut, and he was left to die in abject pain. Oh. I mean, that is interesting that they chose that as a name,
因为，你知道，那是秃鹫最终死亡的故事。但这也是对他们试图避免的命运的提醒。是的。而且我认为我发现的一个聪明之处是，他们在公共宣传中使用了这个关于贾塔尤的神话。所以他们经常从一个村庄走到另一个村庄，与人们交谈，试图让人们关心秃鹫。引用这个故事，对于印度许多人来说，这是他们对秃鹫的主要参考点之一。这算是唯一积极的一个，你明白我的意思吗？
because, you know, that's the story of a vulture ultimately dying. But it's also this reminder of the faith that they're trying to avoid. Yeah. And I think one thing I found kind of clever is that they use this myth about Jatayu in their public messaging. So they go often from village to village and talk to people and try and get people to care about vultures. Referencing this story, which is for a lot of people in India, it's like one of their main kind of reference points for vultures. It's kind of the one positive one, you know what I mean?
所以维布告诉我，他们一直在努力说服农民不要使用黑市双氯芬酸或其他有毒药物。维布的团队收集尸体样本并进行常规药物测试。他们寻找安全的替代品，并游说政府和制药公司销售这些替代品。他们还潜入药店，假装是一个有病牛的农民。他们会看看医生是否仍然开出所有这些有毒药物。哦，哇。哇。
So Vibhu told me that they're constantly working to persuade farmers to not use black market diclofenac or other toxic drugs. Vibu's team collects carcass samples and they do routine drug tests. They find safe alternatives and they lobby the government and pharmaceutical companies to sell those instead. They also go undercover in drug stores, pretending to be a farmer with a sick cow. And they'll see if doctors still prescribe all these toxic drugs. Oh, wow. Wow.
是的。这真的是亲力亲为的工作。是的。我的意思是，他们真的在各个方面进行战斗。我的意思是，上帝保佑他们。他们还在全国范围内实施了所谓的“秃鹫安全区”或VSZ。所以这些VSZ，就像那些半径100公里的区域，他们真的、真的非常努力地与农民和其他所有人合作，确保该区域没有双氯芬酸。他们已经开始在这些地区进行一些放归测试，想法是让我们从某个地方开始，也许有一天，完全放归这些鸟类将是安全的。
Yeah. It's really hands-on work. Yeah. I mean, they're really fighting on all fronts. I mean, just God bless them. They've also implemented something across the country called Vulture safe zones, or VSZs. So these VSZs, like that areas where there's a hundred kilometer radius area where they really, really work hard with the farmers and everybody else to make sure that that area is diclofenac free. They've already started doing some test releases in these areas and the idea is that let's start somewhere and maybe one day it'll be safe to fully release these birds.
是的。但我的意思是，这其中的大问题是秃鹫会飞，我想它们飞的距离远不止100公里。它们可以。是的。所以这是一个有趣的事情，策略是建立这个区域，但归根结底，这是一个想象中的区域。这是一条想象中的线，秃鹫并不了解这一点。但维布和其他人会告诉你，至少这总比什么都没有强。是的。我很高兴他们正在尝试一些东西。那么印度以外的秃鹫情况如何？
Yeah. But I mean, the big problem with that is that vultures can fly and I imagine they fly a lot further than 100 kilometers. They can. Yeah. And so it's it's this interesting thing where the strategy is to create this zone, but ultimately it's an imaginary zone. It's an imaginary line that it's not like the vultures are aware of this. But Vibhu and others will tell you that at least it's something. Yeah. I'm glad that they're trying something. And so what's going on with vultures beyond India?
是的。那么印度以外的秃鹫情况如何？是的，南亚的每个国家都在自己的旅程中。情况略有不同，因为，你知道，政府会做出不同的决定。有很多不同的力量在起作用，这意味着每个国家似乎都在经历这个问题的不同版本。不过，一个有趣的成功故事是尼泊尔。很难比较这两个国家，尼泊尔和印度，因为你知道印度大得多。这场灾难也
Yeah. And so what's going on with vultures beyond India? Yeah, every country in South Asia is on its own journey. And it's slightly different because, you know, the governments will make different decisions. There's a lot of different kind of forces at play that mean that every country kind of is seeing a different version of this. An interesting success story though is Nepal. It's hard to compare the two countries, Nepal and India, because you know India is much larger. The catastrophe was also
大得多。那里有更多的秃鹫。而且，双氯芬酸在印度上市的时间比尼泊尔早几年。所以当他们发现双氯芬酸是问题所在时，还有一点点时间。在尼泊尔发生全面崩溃之前，他们有更多的时间。但尼泊尔采取了一种非常有趣的策略，许多人将其视为成功的原因之一。除了秃鹫安全区和圈养繁育（尼泊尔也有），他们还有一个名为“秃鹫餐厅”的社区主导的努力。这不是一个新概念。它是从欧洲和非洲的保护工作中借鉴来的。
much larger. There were more vultures there. But also, Diklofenak came on the market in India several years before Nepal. And so by the time they found that diclofenac was the problem, there was just a little bit more time. They had more time before a total collapse happened in Nepal. But Nepal has taken on a really interesting strategy that a lot of people point to as one of the reasons for its success. Besides vulture safe zones and captive breeding, which they have also in Nepal, they also have a community-led effort called Vulture Restaurants. It's not a new concept. It was borrowed from conservation work in Europe and in Africa.
但秃鹫餐厅本质上是露天区域，在田野里，所以不是圈养，秃鹫已经习惯了在那里获得食物，特别是药物安全的食物。所以人们会去测试这些药物并带去一堆食物。它甚至成为了一种促进当地经济的方式。它变成了一种旅游景点，人们会来，付一些钱观看这些秃鹫进食。这是秃鹫已经习惯的事情，就像，好吧，这里、这里和这里是可靠的持续食物来源。
But vulture restaurants are essentially areas out in the open, in fields, so not in captivity, where the vultures have gotten used to food being provided for them, specifically drug-safe food. So people will go test these drugs and bring a bunch of food. And it's even become kind of a way to boost local economies. It's turned into kind of a tourist attraction where people will come, they'll pay some money to watch these vultures eat. It's a thing that vultures have gotten used to, like, okay, here and here and here are reliable sources of consistent food.
我要去这里，而不是需要自己寻找食物。尽管它是在野外，但它很有效。那么你认为印度秃鹫的未来会怎样？我认为很清楚的是，印度的秃鹫种群永远不会回到曾经的样子，即使种群是稳定和健康的。这是因为人类和动物一直在不断适应。现在秃鹫消失了，印度的城市和邦正在努力解决如何处理那些直接暴露在外的死牛，他们试图把它们围起来
I'm going to go here instead of needing to look for my own food. Even though it's out in the wild, it's been effective. And so what do you think the future is going to hold for vultures in India? I think what's clear is that the population of vultures in India is never going to go back to what it once was, even if the population is stable and healthy. And that's because humans and animals were continuously adapting. And now that the vultures are gone, cities and states in India are grappling with what to do with their dead cows that are just lying open and they're trying to corner them off
并把它们放进这些垃圾场或焚烧炉里。这对秃鹫意味着什么，如果它们回归的话，它们的食物供应将大幅减少。在它们缺席的情况下，我们将，我们，我们需要适应，你知道，我们需要想出一个新系统。所以这是一个来回的过程。这是一个持续的事情。当想到印度秃鹫的未来时，我想留给你一个维布留给我的画面，那就是在未来，如果我们看到，你知道，这些秃鹫的成功放归，即使它们全部
and put them in these dump sites or in these incinerators. What that means for vultures, should they return, is that their food supply will be dramatically reduced. And in their absence, we're gonna, we're, we need to adapt, you know, we need to figure out a new system. And so it's this back and forth. It's this continuous thing. When it comes to thinking about the future of vultures in India, I think an image that I just want to leave you with is an image that Vibhu left me with, which is that in the future should we see, you know, successful releases of these vultures, even if they all
被放归，现实是它们可能无法在城市地区生存。它们可能不再像孟买的通古瓦迪那样成群结队地涌向城市地区，因为有太多其他东西挡路了，这些阻挡它们飞行路径的高层建筑。印度这个国家正在经历这个快速的电气化过程。所以所有这些电线都挡住了秃鹫的路。
get released, the reality is that they might not survive in urban areas. They might not flock to urban areas anymore, like places like Tunggurvadi in Mumbai, for example, because there's so many other things that are in the way, these high rise buildings that are blocking their flight path. The country of India is going through this rapid process of electrification. And so all of these wires are in the way of the vultures.
也许未来秃鹫会把自己限制在更受保护、更野生的区域。它们待在山上、悬崖边，它们待在森林里。三十年前，秃鹫可以在德里生存，但现在它们不能了。所以现在最终秃鹫将被限制在保护区内。这是必然会发生的。我问维布，这个前景让他感觉如何。你知道，在他的童年时代，他非常习惯于到处看到秃鹫。很多人也是。
And that maybe what the future holds is that vultures kind of cordon themselves off to areas that are more protected, that are more wild. They stay on the mountains, the cliff sides, they stay in the forests. Thirty years ago, vultures could survive in Delhi, but now they cannot. So now ultimately vultures will be confined to protected areas. That is going to happen. I asked Vibhu how the prospect of this made him feel. You know, in his childhood, he was so used to seeing vultures just everywhere. So many people were.
但如果秃鹫永远不再回到这些地方怎么办？我想那会是好事。在我们没有资源的时候，它们为我们提供了很好的服务。现在我们必须自己照顾牛了。是的，我们已经证明自己不是很好的邻居。所以，为了它们自己的利益，也许它们最好还是为了它们自己的好而远离。这真的非常迷人，拉莎。非常感谢你抽出额外的时间，以及你制作的美丽故事和所有这些额外的信息。我喜欢这些东西。学习让我感到非常快乐，我很感激你花时间和我谈论这些。
But what if vultures never returned to these places? I think that will be good. They had done a good service for us when we didn't have the resources. Now we have to take care of the cattle ourselves. Yeah, we've proven ourselves to be not very good neighbors. So, for their own sake, maybe they should just stay away for their own good. This is really fascinating, Anlasha. Thank you so much for this extra time and just the beautiful story that you produced and all this extra information. I love this stuff. It makes me so happy to learn and I appreciate you taking the time to talk to me about it.
非常感谢。这真的很有趣。这期《99%隐形》的番外节目由拉莎·马丹报道。拉莎的报道得到了国际妇女媒体基金会、霍华德·G·巴菲特妇女记者基金的支持。混音：哈西克·本·艾哈迈德·法里德。音乐：斯旺·里尔。感谢本期节目的秃鹫专家：维布和尼基塔·普拉卡什、米拉·苏布拉马尼安和穆尼尔·瓦拉尼。
Thanks so much. This was really fun. This bonus episode of 99% of Invisible was reported by Lasha Madan. Lasha's reporting was supported by the International Women's Media Foundation, Howard G. Buffett Fund for Women Journalists. Mix by Haseek Bin Ahmad Fareed. Music by Swan Real. Thanks to this episode's vulture experts, Vibhu and Nikita Prakash, Mira Subramanian, and Munir Varani.
如果你想了解更多关于秃鹫的信息，我强烈建议你去关注他们的所有工作。凯西·图是我们的执行制片人，柯克·科尔斯塔德是数字总监，德莱尼·霍尔是我们的高级编辑。团队其他成员包括克里斯·贝鲁贝、杰森·德莱昂、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、薇薇安·勒、乔·罗森伯格、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼、凯利·普莱恩、雅各布·马尔多纳多-梅迪纳、莎拉·贝克、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、尼娜·波图克，以及我，罗曼·马斯。《99%隐形》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。
If you want to learn more about vultures, I highly recommend you go and follow all of their work. Kathy Tu is our executive producer, Kirk Kolstad is the digital director, Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Berube, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Vivienne Le, Joe Rosenberg, Gabriella Gladney, Kelly Prine, Jacob Maldonado-Medina, Sarah Bake, Christopher Johnson, Nina Potuck, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence.
如果您想了解更多关于秃鹫的知识，我强烈建议您去关注他们的所有工作。Kathy Tu 是我们的执行制片人，Kirk Kolstad 是数字总监，Delaney Hall 是我们的高级编辑。团队的其他成员包括 Chris Berube、Jason DeLeon、Emmett Fitzgerald、Vivienne Le、Joe Rosenberg、Gabriella Gladney、Kelly Prine、Jacob Maldonado-Medina、Sarah Bake、Christopher Johnson、Nina Potuck，以及我，Roman Mars。99% Invisible 的标志是由 Stefan Lawrence 设计的。
We are part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building, in beautiful Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on all the usual social media sites as well as our new Discord server. There's a link to that as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们隶属于Stitcher和SiriusXM播客家族，目前总部位于奥克兰市中心以北六个街区的潘多拉大厦，那里风景优美。您可以在各大主流社交媒体网站以及我们新的Discord服务器上找到我们。在99PI.org网站上，您可以找到Discord的链接以及99PI往期的所有节目。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。